mental health is one example of a data
gap there's no single study which
analyzes mental health and the outcomes
for people from
ethnic backgrounds the center on the
dynamics of ethnicity pulled together a
number of different studies to show that
the risk of being diagnosed with a
serious mental disorder
is five times higher if you're black
than if you're white
but it draws on nhs data which stopped
being recorded
10 years ago now suffering poor health
in old age is another example
20 of white british people aged 80 to 89
say they have poor health that's the
line at the bottom but look at the
yellow line this shows the same
proportion of people
from bangladeshi heritage age 50 to 59
years old say they have poor health
but there's no single study collecting
data on health
in relation to older people from
ethnically diverse
backgrounds similarly the home office's
own
racial disparity unit released this data
in march it shows how the stop and
search rate for black people
was four times higher than for white
people in london
and this increases to eight times more
likely for black people
in avon and somerset and 23
times more likely for black people in
dorset the biggest disparity in the
country but
no one is investigating why these rates
differ
so greatly scientists claim that it's
these data gaps which lead to
ineffective policies
they hope this major new research
project
will help